in this video I want to talk about the
carbonic acid bicarbonate buffer system
as it applies to the human body okay
now if you recall back to general
chemistry a buffer is something that
resists changes in pH so pH is a measure
of hydrogen ion concentration so protons
really so for instance bicarbonate can
act as a buffer in that if there's too
much H+ around it can pick some up and
become the protonated version of it
which is this carbonic acid or if
there's too little h+ around and the pH
or the H+ concentration needs to
increase then bicarbonate could donate
its proton to the environment in any
case I don't want to talk too much about
that that's G chem stuff but in
biochemistry but I don't want to talk
about specifically is how this applies
to human biochemistry right so we as
humans right we breathe in oxygen and we
undergo a cellular respiration and we
convert glucoses to carbon dioxide now
for a moment in our metabolizing tissues
that let me end up exhaling that that
carbon dioxide but before we exhale it
that carbon dioxide exists in our blood
so what happens there this is what's
going to go on there so carbon dioxide
right is a gas and it will dissolve in
water right in our blood excuse me
and when they come together it will form
carbonic acid right this is this
reaction doesn't just happen it's enzyme
catalyzing the enzyme that does this the
cat
Wise's reaction is called carbonic
anhydrase and we haven't talked yet
about enzymes these videos just yet but
we're going to talk about them a much
much more later but for now you guys
probably already familiar with the idea
that an enzyme speeds up a particular
chemical reaction allows chemical
reaction to happen so we take carbon
dioxide and water form this carbonic
acid now this carbonic acid right is an
acid so it is a proton donor so it'll
join it a proton to the environment and
it will be left as bicarbonate okay
now what's going on here so when we
consider this whole reaction scheme we
definitely want to think about back to
general chemistry the idea the shot
liege principle so I'll just write that
here
let's shot the A's principle if you
recall back to two general chemistry let
Shotley A's principle was the whole idea
behind equilibrium is that if a
particular reaction is at equilibrium
and it is disturbed somehow it will
account for that difference so as to
re-establish equilibrium so what I want
to get at is how carbon dioxide is
related to H+ concentration and
therefore pH okay so what happens or
what happens if we if we increase if the
carbon dioxide concentration increases
alright with a bunch of carbon dioxide
what happens so if this reaction is at
equilibrium and we increase the amount
of carbon dioxide we're disturbing the
equilibrium now when that happens if
there's a bunch of this right that's
going to shift the reaction to the right
right now if that happens we're going to
take this and shift to the right or to
create more of this acid and eventually
we have to shift it more to the right so
this is going to cause an
increase in the proton concentration
right so an increase in the carbon
dioxide concentration of carbon dioxide
or if there's just more carbon dioxide
around that's going to cause a shift to
the right in the equilibrium causing the
increase in H+ concentration proton
concentration now what does that
translate into in terms of pH right an
increase in H+ concentration means more
acidic right more acidic is a lower pH
okay so now on the flip side right if
actually before I even mention that this
right this is very very acidic right
these this this case here let me
actually I like that right this is
acidic right this here acidic right a
low pH or a high H+ concentration
describes the acidic environment right
so an increase in carbon dioxide
concentration in the blood right so
happening in the blood I should probably
note that here that's going to make the
environment acidic now that is termed
this whole idea here is termed acidosis
if you've heard that medical term before
okay that's when the pH of the blood
becomes too low or too acidic okay now
on the on the flip side right if we have
a decrease a decrease in carbon dioxide
right the pressure of carbon dioxide
then what's going to happen if well if
we decrease the amount of this then the
reaction has to in order to re-establish
equilibrium has to shift to the left so
it's going to shift to the left we're
going to use up H pluses and they're
going to go this way right to the left
now if that's going to happen then we're
going to decrease H+ concentration and
that will mean an increase in pH
right so that's going to describe a
basic environment right so if the basic
environment what we have what we call
that we don't call it basic OSIS what we
call it as alkalosis okay so why am I
even mentioning this right who cares
well the reason why is because these
things you might might already figured
our ID is that these things are not good
right our body needs to maintain or at
least our blood different areas our body
need to maintain optimal PHS and any a
small change in pH can be very very
damaging and the reason why we'll talk
about later is because proteins function
at particular ph's and the change in pH
can change the structure or protein or
proteins and therefore change their
function if their function is
compromised that could be a really a bad
thing right that could result in death
so the reason why why I'm even
mentioning this right I want to write
this down really quickly is because even
small changes in pH can be very bad or
very damaging potentially
life-threatening
all right I think the optimal blood pH
is approximately 7.4 so a change a
change from this from this pH could be
very very bad for the our blood proteins
including particularly hemoglobin which
carries carries oxygen in our in the
blood which of course we'll talk about
later now what I want to mention further
is the ideas of hyperventilation and
hypoventilation now so first I want to
describe I want to define ventilation
like the color orange
so ventilation you may have all heard
that word you may have even heard
hyperventilation hypoventilation may not
be totally clear on what those things
are now when you think about ventilation
right you might have heard the term like
if you know if you're down in the dumps
and you want to talk to your friend
you're going to vent to them so that
sort of implies that you're going to let
it all out to them you're going to tell
them everything so you're letting
everything out when it applies to
breathing right ventilation we're
talking about breathing out okay so if
we're breathing out what do we breathe
out we breathe out humans breathe out
carbon dioxide okay so you knowing this
right knowing that ventilation right or
if we just consider it as being you know
breathing out co2 then what is
hyperventilation well hi
ventilation would be breathing out too
much right hyper usually implies much or
a lot of lot of ventilation so we're
breathing out in this case too much co2
okay breathing out too much co2 so what
does that mean well if we're breathing
out too much co2 what does that mean for
our co2 concentrations or the pressure
of co2 in our blood so if we're reading
out too much that means we have a little
bit left where we have too low an amount
of co2 in our blood right if we're
breathing out all of it or a lot of it
then we have a very small amount of co2
in our blood so we have a decreased
amount of co2 if a decreased amount of
co2 how does that change its equilibrium
well if we decrease this right we want
to make more how do we make more shift
this reaction to the left so when that
happens we're going to take these H plus
constant H pluses and this bicarbonate
and just shift the entire reaction to
the left to create more co2 so what does
that cause that causes a decrease in H+
concentration so a decrease in H+
concentration means what for our pH well
it's an increase in pH right so so that
that is what is that that is alkalosis
right so this is a problem right if
you're hyperventilating your your blood
is going to be at a high pH which is not
good obviously okay so on the flip side
we have hypoventilation okay this would
mean that
breathing out too little right you're
venting less right hypo means less so
breathing out too little
oops to the tool co2 right so if you're
breathing out too little co2 that means
you have a lot of co2 in your blood
right so we have an increased amount of
co2 we have an increased amount of co2
it's going to shift the reaction to to
use up that co2 and create more H pluses
so we're going to have an increase in H+
concentration and that's going to be a
decreased pH right or acidosis okay now
obviously both of these things are
problems right we want to fix these
problems so how to solve them how do we
do that all right so we're going to talk
about so how to fix okay
so how are we going to fix
hyperventilation if we're
hyperventilating well we are breathing
out too much co2 right so we have a
decreased amount of co2 in our blood so
what do we want to do in order to fix
this problem we want to increase the
amount of co2 right so what you'll often
know is that some you may have already
noticed this at some times that someone
is hyperventilating you you people give
them a paper bag to breathe in in out of
or sees me to breathe out in to and then
breathe back in through so you breathe
into and out of a paper bag why is that
breathe into and out of a paper bag why
well because any co2 that you breathe
out you'll be breathing right back in so
anything if you're breathing out too
much you're letting too much of it out
anything that you let out will come
right back inside of you right so you
get that co2 back in you you increase
this when you increase the the carbon
dioxide concentration
um you end up increasing the H+
concentration thus decreasing the pH
back to normal because you can breathe
in or breathe back in all or most I
don't say all all or most of the carbon
dioxide you exhaled right hopefully that
makes sense now
what about hypoventilation for
hypoventilation you're breathing out too
little co2 right so you have too much
co2 in you well how do you fix this well
you want to get rid of that co2 right so
you would just breathe out or breathe
faster breathe out more or faster right
so that you can let out right more co2
okay so um I'm not a medical
professional I am NOT a medical
professional so take everything I say
with a grain of salt but generally
speaking these two these two sort of
how-to fixes are sensible given this is
given this basis for the before
everything we're talking about the
evenness reaction that's a basis for
everything we're talking about so
hopefully that was helpful and I'll see
you guys in the next video